pero
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en español en
esta oportunidad nos acompaña jorge
sainz él es periodista chileno y se
encontraba realizando varios trabajos
además de un documental en afganistán
mientras las tropas extranjeras se
retiraban y el país regresó a estar bajo
el control absoluto del grupo talibán él
fue protagonista y testigo de escenas
extremadamente duras y trágicas en un
momento histórico para el país jorge 6
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
tramas 24 muy amable a ustedes y
muchísimas gracias por la invitación es
muy contento de poder compartir esta
situación que fue absolutamente
catastrófica dramática en la evacuación
terrible así que bueno hoy día
continuamos con la misma historia
estructura que no se ha acabado también
me persigue así que bueno está aquí
solamente es personal es mi
agradecimiento por carteristas nueva por
favor gracias a ustedes jorge por su
presencia en la entrevista su salida de
afganistán fue agónica de un peligro
extremo casi mortal diría no y además
fue contrarreloj porque los oficiales de
inteligencia jorge también ha asegurado
que acá caería en manos de los
insurgentes por lo menos en unos cuantos
meses no sin embargo pasaron 24 horas
los talibanes irrumpieron en la ciudad
incluso al presidente artur afgana
abandonó el país y los talibanes
finalmente volvieron a tener el poder
vos viviste y viste momentos y
situaciones de una dureza casi
inimaginable jorge cómo fue esa odisea
casi de terror como decía para salir del
país y además algo que es muy destacable
no te fuiste solo sino que ayudaste a
tres mujeres afganas a salir verdad
terrorífico francamente terrorífico
hasta el último momento en que
entrevistado al director de la
televisión nacional afgana es me aseguró
que por lo menos quedan seis semanas
para que llegaran los talibanes a cabo
en es no pasaron dos horas y ya estaban
ahí la guardia el aeropuerto por una
cosa de inclusión y en ese momento me
arrestan por estar grabando en un área
militar y los militares que me retan
salen argumentando me dicen los
talibanes están a 2 km ahí yo no inicié
una salida catastrófica por el centro de
la ciudad con mis productores en un
momento cada uno dijo aunque todo el
mundo venía de distintos lados los
refugiados que llegaron a todas las
áreas se vieron en momentos muy muy
duros en que todo el mundo estaba muy
muy asustado también por por supuesto
mis traductores productores que son los
sólidos y los ojos de un periodista
extranjero
porque vos estuviste en lo que fue todo
este proceso no entregue el de la
avanzada del grupo talibán con la
retirada de las tropas extranjeras como
fue cambiando kabul como fue cambiando
el país previo no a la retirada de las
tropas hasta que finalmente los
talibanes se hicieron con el poder
absoluto
esto lo viví de una manera muy directa
porque yo estaba realizando muchísimas
entrevista especialmente con los grupos
que estaban más afectados es decir
comunidades étnicas comunidades
religiosas como los chiquitas
y especialmente mujeres berlín de las
mujeres que por ejemplo campeonas en
fútbol en básquet o en voleibol mujeres
que habían estudiado en el conservatorio
por 20 años un piano y que me decían si
llegan los talibanes yo me suicido por
lo tanto es ese tipo testimonios son muy
fuertes luego traté de volver al
conservatorio nacional de música todos
los instrumentos estaban destruidos por
lo tanto el cambio con muy violento muy
rápido ahora mismo por ejemplo con la
entrevistadora más importante de la
televisión al canal ella de pasar de un
estudio los típicos estudios de un
canal de televisión a estar solista en
el aeropuerto refugiada en un rincón
desde ahí encontramos la volvemos a
grabar cuando sentimos que ella misma
noticia y me vienen a buscar en ese
momento fue terrible y logramos gracias
a la intervención
gracias a los contactos que teníamos
conectando el país que ellos
intervinieron con el ministerio de
defensa y logramos algunos cupos dentro
de los aviones españoles que eran de las
pocas en uno de los pocos países que no
estaba pidiendo documentos no estaba
pidiendo pasaportes no tenía pasaporte
estadounidense señor podían salir con
los estadounidenses pero esta gente no
tenía nada así que dramático el último
momento y día a día iba creciendo cuando
estuvimos a dejar la primera niña los
avales no estaban por encima al otro día
estaba todo bloqueado
sucesivamente ahora jorge finalmente
logré salir de kabul y llegaste a españa
a la base de torrejón verdad que sucedió
desde entonces comenzó una nueva etapa
me imagina no dejaste atrás lo sucedido
continúas en comunicación con las
mujeres a jóvenes que ayudaste o con
personas que quedaron en kabul
justamente en estos mismos momentos me
encuentro tratando de encontrar con
muchas dificultades porque estas
personas muchas están en estado de shock
muchas están también extremadamente
cautelosas hay que tener también de que
pueden haber algún tipo de incidencias
las están investigando también que no
estén vinculadas con nada así que cuesta
tener estas entrevistas acabo de
entrevistar a la presentadora de
televisión justamente ella sufriendo
básicamente por sus familias que no las
pueden traer en el caso de esta
presentadora tiene tres hijos allá bueno
mañana sigo estando acá por galicia
luego tengo que volver a otra área en el
norte de españa después para movilizarme
a francia donde hay otras personas que
gracias a nuestra intervención logramos
sacar de este infierno que fue que
estamos así que esta historia nos
persigue estamos haciendo un documental
una historia larga de 100 minutos una
obra 40 en que vamos a contar lo que fue
las alternativas de este escape de cagua
y obviamente sus incidencias que no
duran hasta el día de hoy
pues como vimos tuvimos muy muy cerca de
no lograrlo recordemos que la bomba
reventó una hora después que nosotros
salimos en esa misma de esa misma salida
es más de cientos cientos de personas en
ese ataque perpetrado por el estado
dinámico el sac exacto así fue porque a
ver en tu trabajo realizando el
documental y las tareas periodísticas
que estabas realizando en la spanish tan
estuviste dialogando con pobladores no
sólo de kabul sino de los alrededores es
verdad quería preguntarte si cambia la
concepción que tienen del grupo talibán
entre personas de diferentes regiones
del país
bueno en general lo que ocurre es que
aquí la escritura social tribal donde
por ejemplo están los pasos a los que
pertenecen los talibanes pero también
los suv de co2 tan chic los turnos los
turcos que los países son batirán es en
fin muchos grupos étnicos que aunque les
dirán lo que digan no van a cambiar la
percepción tiene mucha mucha
desconfianza de los grupos talibanes y
particularmente yo cuando hablo de unos
pues porque son un hombre la de
distintos distintos como por algunos más
moderados pero en general por lo que
vimos fue la composición del gobierno
por lo que yo estoy hablando con estas
personas que están vinculadas a las 24
horas con distintos grupos allá en kabul
es en edad es más ancha dice en kandahar
me dicen que esto no ha cambiado en
absoluto y que incluso actualmente todo
el nuevo govern gobierno todas las
personas más duras del régimen talibán
sé que esto no va a cambiar por ahora
hay una cosa de traumatismo hermetismo
con china pragmatismo con pakistán que
son las principales influencias que
tienen los talibanes pero sin parís creo
que viene es un régimen muy muy duro por
el momento las mujeres están
completamente apartadas y están siendo
duramente reprimidas si el panorama no
es para nada alentador porque ahora si
tenemos en cuenta la manera en que se
llevó a cabo lo que fue la retirada de
las tropas extranjeras sumado esto al
hecho de que 20 años después de guerra
se fueron los estadounidenses y las
tropas de la otan y los talibanes casi
sin ningún tipo de conflictos llegaron
al poder en tan sólo pocas semanas se
generó teniendo en cuenta esto entre los
afganos cierto disgusto o rechazo hacia
eeuu podéis observar esto muy grande muy
muy grande y yo con mucho miedo para
realizar el trabajo periodístico de
partida no podía hablar ni siquiera en
español porque me podían calificar como
estadounidense porque él nos reconocen
ellos tanto entre las lenguas
extranjeras luego había un gran odio un
gran gran y después lugar hacia la
actitud de todo eeuu porque él tuvieron
mucho tiempo para haber realizado esta
actuación de otra forma
y finalmente
la evacuación que quedó ahí con tantos
norteamericanos en el terreno con tantas
personas que habían trabajado con ellos
esto ha generado una tremenda
desconfianza no solamente en afganistán
test sino que también en irak donde eeuu
anuncia que va a salir hacia diciembre
de este año y también en otros lugares
donde el base norteamericana de grande
una gran presencia norteamericana por lo
tanto esto se está transformando en un
problema mayor para todo esto que es la
influencia norteamericana
estadounidense en el mundo no solamente
en afganistán una pérdida de confianza
en como ellos logran defender a sus
aliados porque ha vivido momentos de
terror por decirlo de alguna manera
verdad estuviste cara a cara con la
muerte diferente a personas realmente
temible es verdad momentos de muchísima
incertidumbre también te transformo esto
jorge que cambio en vos
bueno cuando nos tiramos al pozo
directamente de agua servida y logramos
sacar a estas últimas personas esa
sensación de que habíamos salido de algo
terrible de una situación una película
de terror con final feliz obviamente que
en el fondo de uno mismo hay un cierto
alivio pero tengo que expresar de que
esto me ha continuado de creo que ya
muchas veces también despierto con
algunas pesadillas
siento que este episodio todavía no ha
terminado y voy a continuar voy a
continuar en áreas en conflicto esta es
una pasión que tiene uno yo creo que en
ese sentido no me ha cambiado nada hoy
día mismo estaba planeando nuevos viajes
hacia áreas en guerra como etiopía por
ejemplo como siria e irak así que bueno
esperamos traer por lo menos dos
testimonios de esa gente que está
sufriendo el problema del conflicto y
este conflicto que está dictado ha
estado tan tapado por el comino y que
hoy día vuelve a resurgir de una manera
tan fuerte como en afganistán
jorge saiz muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la prevista de france 24 ha
sido realmente un placer dialogar con
usted
muchísimas gracias a todos los auditores
de france
france 24 y muchas gracias a ti por esta
excelente entrevista y un saludo
obviamente al público latinoamericano al
público de habla hispana que nos escucha
muchas gracias por
escucharnos y dándose esta oportunidad
no por favor gracias a ustedes
nuevamente en nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en france 24 y en france 24
punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y